en septembre vaccination obligatoire des
enseignants le les soignants aujourd'hui
et après en fonction de l'évolution
laisser la possibilité aux gouvernants
exactement comme l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
on a laissé la possiblité au
gouvernement de faire un confinement
total un confinement partiel en
confinement territorialisée des mesures
de couvre-feu sur la vaccination il faut
qu'on soit exactement dans les mêmes
dispositions
c'est à dire que tant que le virus
circule à bas bruit dire on n'est pas
obligé de passer à l'obligation
vaccinale complète en revanche on peut
sur le plan territorialisée ou par
secteur d'activité parce qu'on peut
penser également aux questions des
forces de l'ordre
on peut poser la question sur les
personnels des collectivités locales
toutes celles et ceux qui sont dans des
lieux où il ya beaucoup de monde le
virus de toute façon il agit là où il ya
beaucoup de monde donc partout où il ya
beaucoup de monde
les professionnels doivent être vaccinés
et les usagers doivent présenter un pass
ali
[Musique]